if you can produce an e-book on your own
and put it up for 99 cents and it can
compete with all the big-name publishers
why aren't more people going to do this
I am Nicholas be with reason TV and
today we're talking with lead doran the
author of an e-book that is burning up
amazon coms bestseller list called
please enroll responsibly lee is also
the author behind the popular video
website at youtube how the world works
leave thanks for joining thanks for
having me tell us about please enroll
responsibly it's a guide for students
and parents about what to do when it
comes to college time what do you what
are you trying to accomplish well I was
receiving emails from parents and
students for quite a while talking about
teachers and professors who were
politically biased and they didn't know
what to do and a lot of times I'd write
really long email responses and I
figured well why not just publish a book
providing some tips and techniques for
parents and students on what to do is it
also a guide to talk about like what
schools you might find more interesting
right I'll go facade of a lot of hard
sciences you can avoid some bias
professors it's not to say take know you
know sociology or the counter to do so
or humanities but it's less likely that
you're going to be inundated with
political ideology than your star tokens
aren't close of course of course and I
don't suggest just avoiding those but it
it's less likely it's going to happen
why an e-book as opposed to going a more
conventional route of getting an agent
at a book publisher I think that's the
way of the future I think more and more
people are going to be able to do it and
if this becomes successful and I don't
necessarily need a publishing arm to get
my book out why are people going to wait
around to get that phone call from a
publishing company or have to go through
pitch after pitch to get someone to
notice them if you can produce an e-book
on your own and put it up for 99 cents
and it can compete with all the big-name
publishers why aren't more people going
to do this talk a little bit about one
of the sources that you provide for your
you know for everybody is how the world
works talk about that at YouTube and how
I came into being and what you're trying
to accomplish with that it was sort of
an accident i always like talking about
politics and so one day about two and a
half years ago i decided hey I'll just
start uploading some videos
my political opinion and I started to
really get some traction and I was able
to develop an audience and even large
networks like Fox News picked up on the
life it was what's your most recent
video up on the stimulus and whether or
not the stimulus was was successful and
many of the fact-checkers on CNN work
were arguing that of course it was it
worked because the CBO said it did well
if you look at what the CBO did it's not
not really a good measure of whether it
was excited they were just checking the
math embedded in the model that the
administration was pushing so assuming
that the administration had calculators
at hand the CV I was going to find yet
it checks out just exactly like they
said right what's the appeal of of your
YouTube videos because I mean you you
get tens and even hundreds of thousands
of views but it's pretty low-tech where
it's I mean you're basically just
talking you know why is that drawing
viewers I actually think that's why it
works on because it doesn't feel like
you have a corporate backing which I
don't I mean I make it some of my videos
in 15 minutes just in my apartment where
I'll just talk to a camera and I try to
research you know that I try to do a lot
of research which people might not not
have time to do and so I think that's
why it takes up a lot of people worried
that you know it's something like
YouTube as well as the internet more
broadly leads to a splintering and a
fragmenting of a common culture do you
buy that or do you think it's it that is
far more outweighed by the ability of
you and other people to actually speak
up it's totally decentralized at this
point and you can get more information
than you ever could before and it's
really no excuse if people choose to
bubble themselves off from other
information especially when it's out
there Leah Doran I want to thank you for
talking to reason TV Lee Doran is the
author of the e-book available at
amazon.com please enroll responsibly and
check them out at YouTube at how the
world works thanks appreciate it
you